welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and these four of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is facing a potential
huge shake-up because of cube gasp but
not within six feet of another person
pandemic related production delays and
sure while this is affecting everything
from sports to blu dungeon air quality
the MCU is not just a single standalone
movie that can be pushed back a few
months it's a living breathing narrative
hivemind of interconnected plot lines
cameos a post-credits scenes they got
released Windows lockdown free blips
worth the time so with black widows
release getting delayed I'm gonna break
down everything we know about this
updated base for schedule new timelines
new storylines and these three ways this
could all go down
okay black widow was originally set to
launch phase 4 on May 1st until the
closure of most cinemas forced disney to
delay the release according to Variety
one individual close to Marvel Studios
claimed the delay affected nothing on
the MCU timeline don't know how they can
see the future so clearly through the
thick clouds of respiratory disease but
if global regions with the biggest film
going markets can flatten this outbreak
curve so that cinema chains reopen and
say July or August Disney does have a
fairly non-competitive window mid August
right before d23 to give Black Widow a
chance at a non-target opening weekend
I'm calling this scenario 1 and it's
really the best-case one because Marvel
could probably stay on schedule from
there forward Falcon when her soldier
could still release in late August
around d23 assuming they finished their
progress in the summer the Eternals is
wrapped and barring major reshoots could
still release November 6 Wan Division
and Loki could resume shooting and come
out December 2020 in early 2021
respectively but what if too many
[ __ ] Spring Breakers in Florida
season too many hot tubs I'm from
Florida it's kind of the past time there
well there are other ways this could go
but it's easy to get burnout here in the
blue dungeon trying to predict these
movies for you my escape lately is into
a dungeon with even more shadows canary
shadows variety thanks the rainshadow
legends for sponsoring this video I love
great shadow legends know you do raid is
a free turn-based RPG with a ton of
champions to choose from you can
download raid for free and you can play
on both mobile and desktop what I like
about the game is making my champions
more powerful over time by winning
battles and sacrificing other champions
to upgrade them
that's right I sacrifice characters you
can't make a rain shadow legends omelet
without cracking some red shadow alleged
eggs and cheese
you also need cheese to make omelets
right now Amazon Prime subscribers can
claim free content just log in to raid
Shadow legends signed up before March
22nd to claim three void shards and for
superior void potions claim your loot
today Bram is on Prime members only
you're almost out of time so go claim
your loot now by installing the game
from my link below and following the
instructions time is running out before
this ends in April but the last drop is
coming soon with a six six star
legendary attack artifact and three
three day XP boosts just go to the video
description click on the special links
and if you're a new player you will get
100,000 silver plus one three champion
hex Weaver besides definitely listening
to sad music she's an awesome champion
that will help you win
oh this treasure will be waiting for you
here in your inbox hurry the rewards are
available only for the next 30 days good
luck and I'll see you there many fans
are pushing Disney to release Black
Widow VOD on Disney Plus the way they
released frozen to in the rise of
Skywalker earlier than they were
expecting to on straining and recent
mid-sized releases like The Invisible
Man and birds of prey are now streaming
I highly doubt Disney will do that for
Black Widow I know I've seen the
argument this is where the future is
going one will do just release enough
people who are making these arguments
don't really understand the economics of
Hollywood Disney needs to make back
hundreds of millions of dollars on Black
Widow to recover the production and
marketing costs that they've already
paid for it they have said they're
aiming for 700 million to 1 billion
dollars they will not get close to that
target by just renting out Black Widow
and Disney Plus folks Disney Plus still
is not available in most countries so if
they put it out on Disney Plus shirt
they'd get that first wave of fans who
pay for the streaming rental but they
would not get that second wave of
general audiences around the world that
these movies need to make the real money
so if Disney can wait for a global
theatrical release weekend for Black
Widow until August
yeah they're definitely gonna do that
but if they can't wait that brings us to
scenario - if this pandemic extends to
the fall or if the currently suspended
productions are unable to resume
shooting this summer that might cause
the MC schedule to shift back by one
release window so Black Widow could
slide back to November 2020 the Eternals
February 2021 shang-chi May 2021 and so
on and so on now
say I do not consider scenario 2 to be
likely because it would mean a huge
overhaul with movies released in that
weird times of the year I think it's
more important to marble that titles
like Doctor Strange to spider-man 3 Thor
4 stick to those exact 2021 released
weekends and I should point out that
this intended phase 4 scheduled was
already an alternate timeline to the one
Marvel likely originally planned on yes
we are living in a simulation and a
Marvel's original timeline they were
called the Berenstein bears Sinbad was a
genie in the 90s and we gave bats
viruses I firmly believe that Marvel's
original phase 4 timeline with not for
black widow to kick off the phase but
for the launch of the new era to be
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 a future
looking cosmic laugh fest with a killer
soundtrack with the moodier spy thriller
prequel black widow coming in the July
slot but then the whole dumb drama with
James Gunn delayed guardians 3 since the
large cast missed its shooting window
and Gunn hopped over to DC to shoot the
Suicide Squad sequel Disney and Marvel
still haven't announced a release window
for guardians 3 and to me that shows
Marvel and Disney are more strategically
minded with their rollout of their
stories not simply shifting everything
back to Pegg but creatively a
rearranging it all the way I mix and
match the toys on the rogue theory wall
when no one is looking Bruce Lee x-men
then Silver Surfer come on so if these
production delays force marble to fully
miss previously announced deadlines I
think it is more likely that we will see
scenario 3 and here's where things get
real interesting okay let's imagine
black widow gets pushed back to a
November 2020 release so if you're Kevin
Feige in that scenario you're really
gonna want a rally in 2021 with your
fans invested and then see you as much
as possible so of all these titles
you've announced which ones are the
ringers well the Eternals looks to be a
very important story that will establish
the ancient history of the MCU with the
Celestials perhaps mutant kind as well
so to me that's a February 2021 release
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness promises to rewrite the rules of
the multi-person MCU I say that's got a
stay at may 2021 fighter man 3 is
probably the biggest title on Marvel's
lineup and both Sony and Marvel needed
to be a hit so that's definitely not
moving from July 2021 the streaming
series will probably sandwiched between
these South and Winter Soldier December
2020 Wan Division March 2021 Loki either
April 20-21 if it ties in to the
multiverse of madness or June 2021 if it
doesn't but where do
to sauly shang-chi well it would depend
on how shang-chi narrative ly fits into
the universe remember Black Panther and
Captain Marvel were both introduced with
solo movies immediately followed by
team-up films that these characters
played significant roles in so is
shang-chi gonna bounce around the
multiverse with Doctor Strange or help
Sony make a ton of money with spider-man
we're fly through space with Thor
probably not right so if Shane she
doesn't have to come out before those
three movies you might see it slide back
to February 2022 followed by black
panther 2 in May 20-22 and maybe ant-man
three in July 2022 those would be
earth-based stories that Shane she could
plausibly tie into and folks this
probably wouldn't be that complicated
for them they probably wouldn't have to
do any more reshooting than a few post
credits scenes and those scenes are
often shot separately from principal
production anyway they shot The Avengers
swarm a scene days before that movie's
premiere and brie Larson said that when
she shot the Captain Marvel post-credits
scene should I even know what movie it
was for that blank stare never left her
face so in this scenario three the
Eternals could end with a post-credits
scene that sets up mutant kind in the
MCU with Wanda Bishop picking up the
baton and the House of M type story over
those six episodes which would then hand
off the baton to the multiverse of
madness and then Thor love and thunder
could end with a post-credits scene
showing the battlefield of new Asgard
being scavenged by the same scavengers
that scavenged the Battle of Earth and
endgame a crew that has the logo of the
ten rings for better or worse Marvel
could have the opportunity to completely
rearrange its timeline and if they're
forced into that position it could be a
good opportunity for them but as we wait
for more details to come out about
Marvel's new phase 4 schedule new
rockstars is working through this period
with a re-watch of the Infinity Saga and
we're gonna start with Ironman all the
cool visual details that Jon Favreau
snuck in there in the subtle ways to set
up the whole series watch along with me
every Friday on discord by becoming a
patron of new rock stars at patreon.com
slash new rock stars comment down below
with which of these fates worst
scenarios you'd prefer follow me a TA
vas follow new rock stars and subscribed
into rock stars here on YouTube for
breakdowns of everything Marvel thanks
for watching
[Music]